[Music]
they took ketamine and drunk a lot of
alcohol
[Music]
what we did for them
[Music]
good morning guys welcome back and if
you're new here i'm zaha i'm a medical
student studying in the uk today i'm
going to the biggest music festival in
the whole of europe i'm going to
glastonbury i'll be seeing kendrick
lamar olivia rodrigo megan the stallion
and so many more artists will be playing
there and usually to get into this
festival you have to pay at least 300
pounds or more but i'll be getting in
for free and actually i'm getting paid
350 pounds by santander and by my
university because i'll be working there
as part of the medical cover i'll be
working with paramedics doctors and
nurses and we'll be dealing with a lot
of drug overdoses like ecstasy cannabis
a lot of drunkenness and other types of
injuries so excited because this is my
first music festival ever and i'll be
seeing kendrick lamar but also i'm kind
of worried about the camping bits
because there's going to be a lot of mud
and dirt and you have to share your
toilet with strangers but hopefully
you'll be okay and i'll see you guys
there
[Music]
okay so we've got saline here we've got
bandages plasters just to clean any
wound that we get we've got first aid
kit we've got a tick remover here this
is to measure the temperature if the
patients have any fever stetoscopes here
this is anaphylaxis kit these are all
for airway management we have our blood
pressure cuff oxygen
anything that you need is here basically
we have the examination bed here
telephones just to communicate with
other paramedics and other first
responders and once we get a patient we
enter their information here what we did
for them they cared for
and yeah
during my eight hour shift i treated a
head injury a burn injury an asthma
attack and a sprained ankle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right look on a map
see where the campsite is then i had a
very late dinner because i didn't get to
eat anything during my shift then went
straight to bed
[Music]
good morning
how was your shift yesterday i got to
see someone who was intoxicated with
drugs so they took ketamine and drunk a
lot of alcohol six-year-old lady had
just tripped over a step and had hit her
head and then the last person hadn't
eaten for a while had drunk a lot of
alcohol had some weed and just felt
really dizzy every time he tried to
stand up so we just thought that was
maybe from exhaustion but we took him to
the medical center just in case
[Music]
hello
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
and terrified
and so many women and so many girls are
going to die because of this and um i
wanted to dedicate this next song to
five members of the supreme court who
showed us that at the end of the day
they truly don't give a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
people like you that need to get
no one
[Music]
you
betrayed me
[Music]
i hope you're happy that they'll be
happier
[Applause]
do you tell her she's the most beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm
there we go
[Applause]
[Music]
did you answer no i was sleeping
[Music]
is
[Music]
do it
[Music]
what we got
[Music]
what we doing
truth is
[Music]
in the real world
[Music]
is
[Music]
wake up
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign